welcome to the meditation on
procrastination
and somewhat ironically i've been
procrastinating making this meditation
so we're all in the same boat together
so as with all meditations posture and
breathing makes a big difference so i
really encourage you find a nice firm
seat to sit on if your legs don't fall
asleep you could sit on the ground as
well but try to sit with your back
upright really good posture
breathe in
breathe out
a little bit slower
a little bit deeper every time
you could lay your hands on your lap i
like to leave them face up
and when you're ready you can soften
your gaze and
slowly close your eyes
breathing in
breathing out
now procrastination is an interesting
thing i'm not sure whether
we human beings are the only animals we
know of that procrastinate it's maybe
worth some research for somebody to
figure that out
but we clearly do it
and a lot of meditation is about
becoming aware of our thoughts
and observing our thoughts and
realizing that we are not our thoughts
even though many times our thoughts seem
to control us or even overwhelm us
and so let's do that
let's try to observe
those thoughts
that are making us put off something
that we know we need to do
why do you think
you are putting that thing off
i'll tell you what it happens to be
usually for my experience it usually is
i'm afraid to start
because i might realize it's
harder than i expected
or
i might not do as well as i expected
or i might make a mistake
maybe i don't think i'm prepared enough
to start
another way to think about it is we're
getting too caught up in the outcome
versus enjoying the journey
or enjoying whatever the thing is that
you're putting off because that's just a
part of this fun experience
and so i find that when i tell myself
self
define yourself by the action not the
outcome
don't define yourself
by whether you succeed or fail
define yourself
as
making the effort
showing up
and enjoying it
laughing at yourself
laughing at this mystery that we call
life
and just putting one foot in front of
the other and realizing it's not so bad
and then you could put the other foot in
front of that one and keep going
and slowly but surely you realize that
you're making a lot of progress
and the more you make that progress
the more that you actually enjoy it
especially if you're not doing it at the
last minute
and now i'll give you about a minute
for you to
repeat something in your mind
that can hopefully
short-circuit any of those thoughts that
have been keeping you from taking action
for the next minute or so repeat to
yourself
that you really enjoy taking action
you're lucky that you're in a position
to be able to take action
the outcome
it is what it is
you enjoy action
you are lucky to be able to take action
the outcome
is what it is
keep thinking that for the next minute
or so and i'll be
back don't worry
all right
so when you're ready really at your own
time
just become a little bit more aware of
your surroundings
a little bit more aware of your body
a little bit more aware of your breaths
and slowly
open your eyes
and so i'll finish with one last tip
sometimes we put something off because
it just feels
big or overwhelming
what i like to do then is say hey
let me just put 20 minutes towards it
and see where i am at the end of 20
minutes
if i didn't make any progress
no big deal
it was just 20 minutes
but if i did make some progress great
i did the 20 minutes i deserve a break
if after a 5 or 10 minute break i'm
ready to put in another 20 minutes
awesome
if at the end of the 20 minutes i want
to keep going i shouldn't stop myself i
should keep going
but when you view things as hey i'm just
committing 20 minutes to something
it doesn't feel as intimidating
you just own it you say hey i can do
anything for 20 minutes
and i can enjoy anything for 20 minutes
and then you'll want to do it put on a
smile on your face and
own that action
and not only will you make progress but
you're going to have a good time
and so take it with that playful mindset
enjoy it smile and just get started
and i think you'll find you'll be
procrastinating a lot lot less